and i understand that you can't get a
lot of people to come back to the office
that you thought it would be like 15
percent who wouldn't come back after the
pandemic but it's really something like
55 percent who say they will never come
back they're never coming back well
doesn't that tell you something about
how much they must have [ __ ] hated
the office to begin with
i'm just asking
i mean yeah i miss my office but i i
want to be at the office they have
proven to everybody all around the world
that they can use technology to do their
job successfully creatively functionally
productively they want to stay at home
raise their kids take care of their
elderly parents and in fact if you say
to them you have to come back to the
office that's our new mandate they'll
say now i'm just going to quit and work
somewhere else so we thought it was 15
we have a sample size about 10 000
people in our supply chain plus our
companies i thought it would be in
accounting logistics compliance
departments the people used to work in
cubicles it's everybody they don't want
to come back and so we have to learn to
live this way and i'm i'm okay with it
it works i find it really interesting
so you're okay with it
okay mike
one of the guys one of the guys that's
you know crucial to our whole
operating company accounting said to me
i grew up on a farm
i'm going back to the farm
i'm going to live on the farm
i'll work for you but it's going to be
from the farm i said cool
i'm okay with it no problem who wants to
live on a farm
he wants to live on a farm yeah i bet
you that ends in about a year
you